[Música]
ya que para mí es muy importante en la
historia de clara clara era secretaria
en una oficina de informática y
computación madre soltera con dos hijas
vivían también con su mamá que durante
el día cuidaba a sus dos niñas ella
adulta mayor con el salario del mes
apenas alcanzaba para los gastos de las
cuatro y ella se pone a hacer números
qué va a pasar cuando me pensión a si
sigo con este mismo salario durante la
pensión va a ser mucho menos y no va a
alcanzar para las cuatro y yo quiero
darle calidad de estudio a mis hijas en
el colegio en la universidad y una vez
es de calidad para mí para mi madre
entonces empiezo a buscar opciones y
trabajando en oficina donde trabaja hay
muchos ingenieros en computación que le
ayudan a quitarse el miedo a la
tecnología a aprender a programar
incluso y es así como logra matricularse
en la universidad y al cabo de algunos
años
y gradúa con un diplomado en computación
de la universidad estatal a distancia
porque les cuento esta historia porque
es la historia por la que hoy estoy aquí
por la que estudiar lo que estudia y es
una breve reseña de la historia de mi
mamá y conversando con ella
nos viene mucho acerca de qué está
sucediendo ahora en costa rica hay
demasiado desempleo hay muchísima
pobreza y al mismo tiempo está la el
otro escenario de la gran cantidad de
empresas transnacionales que vienen a
nuestro país y les está costando llenar
las plazas vacantes pero esas plazas
vacantes son específicamente en el área
de servicios en el área de ciencia
tecnología ingeniería en matemática por
sus siglas en inglés stem y no es por la
calidad del recurso humano en costa rica
y estamos excelentes es por la cantidad
no estamos logrando ser lo suficiente
productivos suficientemente productivos
como país para generar la cantidad de
recurso humano preparaban este tipo de
carreras qué tanta oportunidad traen y
esto es muy importante porque
necesitamos que estas empresas
permanezcan entonces cómo hacemos para
que estas empresas consigan la cantidad
de gente que necesitan tanto las
transnacionales como las nacionales y
cuál sería el impacto para nuestro país
me gustaría presentarles acá dos
contextos el primero en costa rica no
estamos graduando la suficiente cantidad
de gente en carreras en stem por ejemplo
más del
97% de los costarricenses mayores de 15
años ya están alfabetizados casi el 100%
los grabamos de la escuela pero sólo el
50 por ciento nos estamos grabando del
cole entonces ahí ya estamos a media
máquina con la cantidad de personas que
podrían decidirse entrar a la
universidad y de los que entró menos de
la tercera parte se están decidiendo por
carreras en stem sólo un 29 por ciento a
nivel país todavía no hay suficiente
interés ahora bien de la cantidad de
oferta en este tipo de carreras
universidades estatales sólo tienen un
37 por ciento y si separamos los números
de las ciencias sociales es sólo un 11%
en la cantidad de carga por las que nos
podríamos decidir en stem no es
suficiente en el 2020 se grabaron 7000
personas en este tipo de carreras pero
hay en 19.000 vacantes
segundo contexto las mujeres en este mes
para el 2019 37 por ciento era el único
porcentaje de mujeres en el área técnica
y para el 2020 todavía menos sobre un 25
por ciento y esto corresponde a la
cantidad de mujeres que se están
grabando estas carreras en comparación
con la de hombres por ejemplo en una
empresa en el área técnica
si tenemos 100 empleados serían 75
hombres y 25 mujeres qué tal si logramos
el equiparar la cantidad sin disminuir
la cantidad de hombres por supuesto 75
mujeres y 75 hombres quiere decir que
serían 150 personas en el área técnica
50% más de producción y si el rifle mus
eso al país entonces
tenemos la cantidad de mujeres para
hacer un plan como éste y estarían
interesadas en este tipo de carreras
pues la mitad de costa rica- somos
mujeres
y muchas buscando oportunidades en costa
rica 1 de cada 6 hogares está en pobreza
o en pobreza extrema y de todos estos la
mitad si no es que más está liderado por
mujeres jefas de hogar madres solteras
que no tienen empleo o no tienen una
profesión qué tal si las acercamos a
este tipo de oportunidades en las
carreras en stem está bien no es algo a
plazo inmediato pero pensemos en el
corto mediano y largo plazo en ellas sus
hijas y sus nietas que normalmente se
mantienen en estos círculos viciosos
sociales de vulnerabilidad
socio-económica les daríamos empleo
oportunidades la sacaríamos de su
vulnerabilidad y además de eso una forma
más fácil de entrar al mercado laboral
por ejemplo hoy decía que 97 por ciento
es la empleabilidad de las mujeres en
este
entonces cuál es el desafío acá cómo
hacemos que las personas en costa rica
de verdad se interesen por las carreras
en stem en la historia de clara como se
imaginan que fue después de 20 años de
haber salido del colegio enfrentarse
otra vez a matt en estudiar trabajar y
tener a sus dos hijas y entrar a aulas
llenas de adolescentes yo el desafío que
veo acá es de la cultura y como dice
peter drucker la cultura se comen la
estrategia en el desayuno es decir el
gobierno y las instituciones no
gubernamentales ya están haciendo de su
parte en la parte de promoción stem de
costa rica pero faltamos como individuos
los costarricenses que haya más interés
y así como podemos hablar de nuestra
biodiversidad de los recursos naturales
con orgullo y ya está mencionar nuestros
premios
podemos hacerlo también de stem y que
éste no sea algo solo de las grandes
conferencias para acá dos fórmulas la
primera llevarlo a casa llevar la
conversación stem la alfabetización
tecnológica en casa porque los niños y
las niñas ya lo están llevando en la
escuela en computación y andreotti acá
pero cuál es el papel de los que estamos
en casa con ellos para que esta
metodología sea también parte del día a
día cuando estamos estudiando español
estudio social de ciencias
que eso también sea parte de el
pensamiento crítico la resolución de
problemas la creatividad la programación
y más allá que eso quitarnos sesgos y
miedos de que matt es muy difícil de que
mate solo para gente muy inteligente de
qué para qué quiero estudiar fórmulas
biología química física eso no se usa
cuando no está trabajando y todas esas
fórmulas que pereza
todos estos sesgos todos estos miedos
son los que cultural y familiarmente
seguimos jalando transmitimos los oímos
los repetimos y los perpetuamos
segunda fórmula
comencemos a acercar de manera más
humana un uno a uno a las personas en
tecnología en ciencias en matemática e
ingeniería pero con las comunidades con
los barrios en las diferentes regiones
del país para que de ver podamos
despertar el pensamiento crítico la
capacidad de asombro y la curiosidad les
pregunto cuántos de ustedes acá saben
acerca de las personas en stem de costa
rica- de los logros y las hazañas
maravillosas que están haciendo en los
laboratorios y en las universidades
de los premios que tenemos de los
descubrimientos los proyectos los
programas de innovación cuántos de
ustedes saben que hoy en la mañana cinco
equipos de costa rica- estaban en el
mundial y en el mundial de robótica en
las olimpiada de robótica cinco equipos
en la final de nuestro país y eso y
muchísimas cosas más que están
sucediendo
entonces para que nosotros y los que
vienen de verdad se proyecten a las
carreras stem tenemos que visualizar los
nombrarlos conversar con ellos llevar
eso al día a día así fue como aprendimos
que existían carreras en pedagogía en
periodismo en enfermería en medicina
porque los veíamos todos los días cuando
éramos pequeños y nos estábamos creando
en la televisión o en casa o en la
escuela
clara hoy ya está pensionado con una
pensión digna y sus hijas pudimos ver
muchas más oportunidades
y esto es una riqueza que pocas personas
ven y yo sé que en costa rica hay
personas que no tienen tal vez todas
estas opciones y tienen situaciones más
graves en especial las mujeres entonces
mi invitación acá es que con estas dos
fórmulas para pesar podamos hacer un
equipo en costarricense
multidisciplinario equitativo en donde
las personas en administración de
empresas en periodismo en política en
sociología en todas las áreas hagamos
mejor la marca stem pero desde cada
costarricense y en cada costarricense
para que sea inclusivo equitativo sea
accesible tenga perspectiva de género es
decir que sea parte de los derechos
humanos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]